ich als bester youtuber breite und
breite und genau so kam ich als
weltbester youtuber von der ganzen welt
biram weltbester von der ganzen welt ich
bin youtuber und als youtuber weiß man
auf die zahl genau wie viele abonnenten
andere youtuber haben und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht wir spielen heute tube
moore lässt wer hat mehr abonnenten
natürlich spielen wir das nur mit
österreichischen youtube
ja wir verschiedene auswahlmöglichkeiten
wie beispielsweise die einstellungen wir
können jetzt hier auf deutschland
österreich weltspitze oder vereinigte
staaten klicken und dann schauen welcher
youtuber dort mehr ja sachs hat also wir
fangen an mit deutschland wir können
jetzt beste kanäle auswählen comedy
unterhaltung spiele praktische tipps und
styling oder musik ich würde sagen wir
kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf beste
kanäle direkt und seen dickster brocken
1,5 millionen what was macht denn
dickster pop thomas selber nachdenken
über den umfragen wahrscheinlich den
dicksten pop ist ein dummkopf
ich weiß nicht wer nichts oder nice also
ich klicke einfach mal niedriger hitze
hat 538 mit dem war ich in alain sutter
safe mehr über eine million also hör mir
1,2 millionen alexy beck sie hat auch
mehr als 1,2 millionen nämlich ein
bisschen mehr 20.000 tricks und auf mehr
als 123 nämlich gibt
jäger das sind richtig klasse calls
gerade top 10 hat auch auf jeden fall
mehr der geht auf die zwei millionen zu
genau heftig glaube ich weniger nämlich
circa eine halbe millionen nie lahm hat
auch weniger nämlich mehr
du hast gepunktet 6
das beste ergebnis konnten steht ich
kann weiter machen damit ich weiter
sehen kann
wir klicken jetzt einfach mal auf neue
spiel starten rem sehen sliwka schau
gegen unsympathisch sascha hat auf jeden
fall weniger nämlich 1,2 millionen
diemer das schwierig ich glaube die man
hat mehr als 1,2 millionen nämlich 1,5
millionen la mia slimani hat weniger
nämlich 766.000 matthew glaube ich auch
weniger nämlich eine halbe million
sie hat auch save mehr als zehn
millionen hat er schon seinen play
button bekommen mister träsch beckert
weniger als zehn millionen nämlich
750.000 germans play hat auch an die
zwei millionen sogar 2,6 millionen krank
alter was sind das für heftige zahlen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen route
de würde ich sagen unter eine halbe
million oder ok 700.000 krass aktiver
schrieb ich glaube jetzt relativ
kratzert 1,8 millionen die prank groß da
habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung ich
würde sagen hör nehmen
die a9 solch wieder weitermachen strand
wars hat 980.000 roth pilz hat glaube
ich weniger nämlich 700.000 sido hat
auch weniger als 100.000 nämlich 670.000
powerpacks kraftvolle bilder in der tat
denke ich weniger als sido nämlich
100.000 weniger sallys welt hat glaube
ich mehr die hat nämlich auch über eine
millionen das ist krass katja krawitz
hat auch über eine million nämlich
weniger
nein so nicht weitermachen park alter
ich dachte wirklich so ich komme safe
die ganze zeit durch und wird das video
an keiner stelle die beenden müssen aber
bei so würde ich mit glatze aussehen
ziemlich krass oder faxen tv oder viel
vielfalt ich glaub faxen tv weniger
nämlich 100.000 weniger als vier fifa
den gästen hat save über eine millionen
nämlich 1,2 millionen schenken glaube
ich auch mehr als 1 konnten
zwei alter das ist nicht mein ziel heute
ist das sich einmal über zehn kommen von
allen guten geistern elektro dance mix
ich wusste nicht wer das ist ein
deutscher kanal ist ich kann den kanal
oder gar nicht wie ip magazin denke ich
weniger nämlich 300.000 weniger julians
blog battle hat mehr über eine millionen
nämlich leon marsch er würde ich sagen
geht auch so an die zwei millionen genau
circa genau zwei millionen galileo
weniger aber auch 15 millionen krass top
welt hat weniger als 1,5 millionen
nämlich 27.000 nie haben hat auch
weniger als 27.000 nämlich wann das
wollte ich nicht sagen ich weiß nicht
genau wer laura joel ist aber dort ende
hat glaube ich mehr als nur ich kann
nicht mehr weitermachen
gamestar hat save mehr als 640.000
abonnenten nämlich fast eine million glp
wieder mit 2,6 millionen bisher der
größte youtuber den wir gesehen haben
galaxy music hat weniger der triathlon
wer ist der thread
haupt nicht abgehoben klingen in
keinster form aber ich kenne mich
einfach echt wenig aus mit der deutschen
youtube sehen und ich bin überrascht wie
viele abonnenten die ganzen kanäle haben
melina hat definitiv mehr als eine halbe
million nämlich auch fast zwei millionen
faxen tv hat weniger m hatten wir gerade
schon milan hat auch weniger hat dk ich
werde immer schlechter rheinufer hat
weniger als zwei millionen nämlich eine
million dem crew hat auch weniger
nämlich 600.000 sascha lag das ist der
bruder von diemer glaube ich ich meine
der hat mehr als 600 22.000 nämlich
900.000 mit den habe ich mal für
klausuren gelernt haben auch 600.000
laura duell hat mehr die wahl war eine
million weiß keine ahnung ich denke mal
niedriger nämlich 840.000 monster
channel 24 kenn ich nicht hat auch
weniger fan video tv kenne ich auch
nicht die haben 582.000 bgh musik kann
ich auch nicht die haben acht alter so
nah dran an der zehn draft roddicks hat
glaube ich weniger als 1,5 millionen
sogar 100.000 weniger wissen abbas hat
auch weniger als 1,4 millionen ähnlich
11 millionen airwave music tv diese
ganze musik channels ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung davon weniger als 1,1
millionen sage ich nehme ich
hunderttausend weniger nizza hatten wir
früher schon hat auch weniger viel
gaming tv hat auch weniger nämlich hat
6000 mehr freunde
gib auf
ich gebe auf das ist das ist magaths
fucking schwierig ich dachte echt ich
kenne mich aus mit irgendwelchen
youtuber zahlen oder irgendwie
abonnenten oder irgendwie sowas aber
diese app hat mir gezeigt dass es nicht
der fall ist vielleicht seid ihr besser
darin ihr könnt ihr morgen in die
kommentare schreiben wo eventuell
gedacht hätte das hätte ich safe gewusst
oder so wahrscheinlich wieder an jeder
situation so wie ich euch kennen sonst
hast doch gerne mal ein like da wäre ich
das ganze eventuell nochmal machen soll
ich meinen wärme noch voll viele
kategorien offen also wir können das ja
ganz auch nur auf spiele beziehen oder
nur auf unterhaltung oft kommen die
musik youtube auch einfach international
mal irgendwie österreich oder amerika
und sonst will ich das video an der
stelle jetzt beenden
und folgt auf instagram wir stehen da
kurz vor zwei millionen abonnenten